today's evidence was all about whether
the mirror group newspapers legal
director knew anything about alleged
phone hacking now Marcus Partington was
cross-examined and repeatedly denied
having any knowledge about any illegal
information gathering techniques he also
said that the legal department wouldn't
need to know the story Source in order
to advise journalists and editors there
was also a brief appearance by John
Cleese in the courtroom he's not part of
this case but he has previously
expressed support for the hacked off
campaign established in the wake of the
2011 phone hacking Scandal but there are
other scores of celebrities who are
currently suing mirror group newspapers
over allegations of widespread phone
hacking in other means of illegally
collecting information now the publisher
group says that they are contesting
these claims and they also say that some
of them have simply been filed too late